being nominated once is really sweet
being nominated twice as a little mime
mind blowing Sarah Paulsen is in a
unique position this year she's up for
two Emmy Awards one for her work as
Marcia Clark on American crime story the
People vs OJ Simpson and the other for
her role as Sally on American Horror
Story hotel et spoke with the actress
Monday in LA at the television Academy's
performers peer group Emmy Awards
celebration where she revealed why she
plans on preparing an acceptance speech
ahead of time probably the better way to
do it because I just fear I would get up
there and just whiteout and just be like
oh just I don't even know what I would
do so if I've got something it would
also help keep me steady from falling
over I might bring someone up just to
hold me if I'm lucky enough to ever be
there but that someone won't be Sarah's
girlfriend Holland Taylor that person's
not my date I'm not telling you as for
what's next
Sarah said she really hopes she can pull
off double duty again and appear in both
of Ryan Murphy's miniseries Shiraz don't
expect season six of American Horror
Story to be about Charles Manson you can
look me right in the eye
you are wrong dead wrong